ha sido una larga noche
y también una larga mañana
pero hemos llegado a un acuerdo anaco
minsk 2 un acuerdo de paz firmado el 12
de febrero de 2015 entre rusia y ucrania
con la mediación de francia y alemania-
el documento se dividió en tres puntos
el más importante el alto al fuego entre
los rebeldes pro rusos y el ejército
ucraniano debía entrar en vigor tres
días después y poner fin a la guerra en
la región del donbass la zona que
comprende a donets y lugansk que se
separaron unilateralmente de ucrania
también contemplaba la retirada del
armamento pesado 48 horas después pero
los intensos bombardeos continuaron en
donestsk sólo unos días después desde
entonces éste se incumple casi a diario
kiev y moscú se culpan mutuamente y
occidente acusa a rusia de armar a los
separatistas pero el kremlin lo niega
la liberación de rehenes fue otro punto
clave del acuerdo y aunque algunos han
pude volver a casa todavía quedan muchos
especialmente en rusia
inscritos también preveía el control
exclusivo de la frontera por parte de
las fuerzas de kiev pero ucrania se negó
a hacerlo mientras siguieran las
hostilidades y hasta que rusia
abandonará la zona mientras moscú
respondía que su ejército no se
encontraba allí
el acuerdo también pretendía garantizar
la soberanía y la integridad territorial
de ucrania un punto que ahora se ve
debilitado por las tropas rusas
concentradas en la frontera siete años
después de la firma del acuerdo ninguna
de las cláusulas se ha aplicado
plenamente
pero marca un precedente y sirve de base
para las conversaciones en curso